Donald Trump is still angry that he lost
the 2020 presidential election and on
the weekend he Unleashed his rage now
directed at the U.S Constitution
do you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out and declare the
rightful winner or do you have a new
election he posted on Truth social a
massive fraud of this type and magnitude
allows for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution
Trump has made bombastic statements in
the past but that a former president
would call for the suspension of the
Constitution was according to a Biden
spokesman and anathema to the soul of
our nation
incoming house Democratic leader Hakeem
Jeffries described it as extraordinary I
thought it was a strange statement but
the Republicans are going to have to
work out their issues with the former
president and decide whether they're
going to break from him and return to
some semblance of reasonableness or
continue to lean into the extremism
Trump has appeared to embrace extremism
since announcing he's launching a third
bid for president in recent weeks he
hosted Nazi sympathizers and Mar-A-Lago
and said as president he'd pardon
rioters who attacked the U.S Capitol the
developments have alarmed some moderate
Republicans who now question whether
Trump should be the party's Presidential
nominee I vehemently disagree with with
the statement that Trump has made Trump
has made you know a thousand statements
in which I I disagree people certainly
are going to take into consideration a
statement like this as they evaluate a
candidate you've got to accept the exact
fact from fantasy and fantasy is that
that we're going to suspend the
Constitution but how will trumps make
America great against supporters respond
will they see his attack on the
Constitution as crossing a line or will
they follow him across ultimately it is
up to the Republican voters to decide
who will be their party's next
Presidential nominee
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington